an diesem tag der damit begonnen hat das
fast in ganz deutschland erstmal der
notruf ausgefallen ist 110 und 112 hier
rufen wir an wenn es wirklich dringend
es ein notfall das ist wenn es um
minuten geht aber heute früh ist unter
diesen notrufnummern 110 und 112 eben
nix passiert sie haben einfach nicht
funktioniert in weiten teilen
deutschlands zerstörung über mehrere
stunden und stunden lang wusste vor
allen dingen niemand warum das ganze
nicht funktioniert hat mehrere
bundesländer waren betroffenen ganz nrw
mann war mitteilungen gab es auch aus
brandenburg aus hamburg hier in berlin
sachsen anhalt rheinland pfalz saarland
teile von mecklenburg vorpommern man
muss sich das vorstellen wenn menschen
dort beispielsweise einen herzinfarkt
hatten oder irgend einen ähnlichen
notfall dann konnten die nicht um hilfe
rufen sie immer noch mal gebiete wo das
überall ausgefallen ist also in diesen
roten gebieten vor allen dingen hat es
eben nicht funktioniert mit dem notruf
heute früh teilweise ganz regionalen
einzelnen kreisen teilweise aber auch
flächendeckend wie patricia gerade schon
gesagt hat in baden württemberg
flächendeckend in sachsen anhalt in
weiten teilen schleswig holsteins und
und und und eben auch in nordrhein
westfalen
und da sind wir jetzt am telefon
verbunden mit dem pressesprecher vom
landesamt für zentrale polizeiliche
dienste so heißt es mit tim wandel
nämlich also per telefon da wo es heute
früh genau diese störung gehabt schönen
guten tag herr wandel
haben sie mittlerweile rausfinden können
warum das nicht funktioniert hat heute
so lange dass man die 110 und 112
einfach nicht erreichen konnte
tatsächlich die notrufnummer 110
landesweit aus bisher ungeklärter
ursache nicht zu erreichen woran es
gelegen hat daran wird natürlich
gearbeitet wird recherchiert und damit
auch mal schauen die hohenstein sprechen
vorbereiten sie sagen dass sie in aller
ruhe herr wandel und das erwarte ich
natürlich auch von den rettungskräften
von den polizeien dass die nicht in
allzu grosse aufregung versetzt werden
und doch das ist ja ein ding zwei
stunden lang alle diejenigen die
versuchen in einem notfall polizei und
rettungskräfte zu erreichen laufen ins
leere finden niemanden telefonieren sich
wohnt in dieser zeit über zwei stunden
und sie wissen noch nicht mal warum das
so war es so dass gott verdankt die
festnetzrufnummer der einzelnen greifen
polizeibehörden weiterhin angerufen
werden konnten deswegen haben wir
veranlasst dass die einzelnen
lokalradios in den kreispolizeibehörden
diese telefonnummern auch verbreitet
haben zusätzlich wurden die social media
kanäle bedient damit haben wir schon
eine menge abgefüllt hat weiterhin haben
wir eine verdoppelung der streifen auf
den straßen dabei geführt zu diesem
zweck haben wir die kolleginnen und
kollegen des nachtdienstes weiter nach
teams belasten und zusätzlich durch den
frühdienst verstärken lassen so dass wir
im prinzip mit mann und maus auf der
straße waren und damit auch eine
doppelte präsenz herbeigeführt haben
konnte die störung mittlerweile behoben
werden und haben sie von zellen gehörten
sie kontakt zu menschen die versucht
haben in der nacht hilfe zu holen und
das hat nicht funktioniert was berichten
ihnen diese menschen also die störung
ist seit 17 vierter in den
kreispolizeibehörden in
nordrhein-westfalen behoben dass die 110
ist wieder erreichbar
fälle wie sie die angeführt haben und
bis dato nicht bekannt na klar weil die
nicht durchgekommen sind wie viele
menschen rufen denn normalerweise an
einem ganz frühen morgen also ich weiß
das aus früheren aus meinen zeiten
frühmorgens das ist so oft die zeit von
herzinfarkten von schlaganfällen und so
weiter wie viele kommen normalerweise
durch auf ihren notfallnummern die
kreispolizeibehörden waren ja weiterhin
erreichbar wir haben durch die doppelte
präsent sicherlich auch eine menge
abgefedert aber hierfür einzel einzelne
sachverhalte da fehlt mir natürlich der
betraut das haben wir ja auch bei uns
knacks schon hier ein bisschen in der
leitung und nach neuesten informationen
das hören wir gerade aus unserer
bildredaktion soll es wohl eine störung
bei der telekom auch gegeben haben das
könnte also die ursache sein für diesen
ja fast bundesweiten ausfall der
notrufnummern 110 und 112 heute früh
aber das ist tatsächlich schon
besorgniserregend dass man so lange zeit
in so vielen regionen deutschlands dann
wenn es um minuten geht niemanden
erreicht auf den bekannten nummern danke
für das gespräch mit ihnen in nordrhein
westfalen von der polizeidirektion dort
im wandel herzlichen dank